début de la course des 24 heures du mans
jacky ickx parle dernier le dimanche à
16h
il franchit la ligne d'arrivée le
premier victoire écrasante de françois
fillon premier tour de la primaire de la
droite et du centre
l'ancien premier ministre sera opposé à
alain juppé au second tour on a
plusieurs c'est un événement
invraisemblable ça pour ma part
extrêmement joyeux très prometteur mais
totalement imprévisible dans cette
proportion
dans ce cas c'est
avant la pause
je n'arrive pas
l'ancien premier ministre est arrivé en
tête dans 87 départements sur 95
alain juppé l'a emporté dans le sud
ouest et en seine saint denis nicolas
sarkozy uniquement en corse
et pas
bédié
ça veut dire qu'il ya une poussée très
forte puissante mais en même temps de
mon point de vue très volatile est très
fragile et je ne crois pas je crois que
c'est une score qui est construit depuis
des années la france n'a pas besoin de
solutions ultra libérale et
conservatrice au contraire porter le
candidat ultra ces ultraconservateurs
ultralibéral ultra anti mariage pour
tous
l'ultra antisociale écoutaient oui j'ai
annoncé que je soutiens de françois
fillon pour trop de raisons principales
un programme qui répond le plus aux
attentes des français
je pense que c'est françois fillon c'est
pour ça que je voterai pour françois
fillon
j'espère qu'on va continuer sur cette
droite ouverte sur cette droite kinowski
parfois transgresse qui pousse les
débats et donc effectivement moi je je
veux très françois fillon prix jeune
femme dérobés et donc je dis clairement
ce que je ferais je voterai pour
françois fillon ont soif ayant apporté à
une famille traditionaliste moi je suis
plus ouvert au modernisme je me sens
plus proche n'est pas françois que de
son ce commun ou de la manif pour tout
ce que j'entendais tout à l'heure à la
jupe et préférer le pape françois à la
manif pour tous je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
est totalement écouté et lu lé pape
françois parce que sur la plupart des
sujets sur lesquels alain juppé semble
vouloir me contester le pape françois
dit la même chose que moi c'est la
défense de ses idées qui me conduise à
apporter mon soutien pour le deuxième
tour alain juppé si vous étiez battu
dimanche
est-ce que vous renom seriez la vie
politique au grand rendez vous 1 on
prend rendez vous on prend rendez-vous
des manchois on verra qui gagne pour ma
part je vais mettre toute la gomme
qu'en pensez vous
et faire rêver les patrouilles de droite
je fais rêver personne moi permettre aux
français d'aller au bout de leur rêve ce
qui est très différent